the skill of just being disciplined
being able to stay on track and just
fight and even take a few knocks and get
back up and just keep you know on that
path or whatever you choose in life
that's a skill I think that'll be with
him forever
I think that discipline to me means
being able to work hard at something
that you strive to achieve and staying
focused on that goal and never letting
it go no matter what you should always
have that ambition and that drive to do
the thing you love to do ever since I
was a little kid I really liked climbing
used to climb everything from fly poles
to before I could walk I used to climb
baby grates and eventually he moved to
basketball goals and he was gonna climb
regardless and someone just introduced
him to rock climbing and it was almost
like love at first sight he was hooked
the first time he ever walked into a gym
my mother has no interest in climbing my
mother grew up in the area where
climbing wasn't even an option no one
even knew been climbing rock on it was a
sport
the fact that I got into it I guess it's
kind of unique because not many people
get to it the way I did my name is Kai
Lightner and I am 14 years old I have no
idea what got him so hooked on
competition climbing
I think of heating forever that competed
at my first Nationals in 2007 he won the
pan-american Championships in Ecuador in
bouldering and sport climbing in 2010 a
woman first ICS national championships
and so far off when it was four years in
a row he recently placed fourth at the
World Championship in his first time
going which is a huge accomplishment
he's won anything you can win in America
you know you wake up and brush your
teeth he wakes up does it work out
brushes teeth because the school comes
home does homework it out go to the
climbing gym and that's his day and
that's what he does it's like who he is
um usually I don't have time to hang out
with my friends after school come on
personal I think I have work I have take
care of basics at the home and then
there's climbing I'm the single mom I
think education is very important it's
probably the most important thing I do
at the moment and it plus it's the only
reason that my mother lets me climb
basically our deal has always been as
long as you continue to bring home the
grades I'll give you my time I'll give
you my money and I'll figure out how to
work everything out and he's been
holding up his end of the bargain so and
2 ahora collaborative traveling you're
always on the go
at the end of the day it's sorted
[Music]
there's not much climbing in
Fayetteville he loves the people loves
the environment but it's not the same as
the competition walls or even the
competition type routes that eave any
clients are compensate and work with
what I have so that I can improve the
triangle Rock Club is about a hour and a
half away and so we end up going there
once a week
[Music]
[Music]
I know what you want and I know what you
want what you want to win practice is
over what what that stakes that yeah
yeah that's what I think
yeah we're going to the nerve of gorge
so do some awesome climbing
[Applause]
[Music]
he just discovered the outdoor climbing
actually gives him a different thrill
also some of his more recent
accomplishments that he's more excited
about or climbing outside he's not so
concerned with the grade he just likes
to push himself so I finally got out in
2002 it's just really awesome
[Music]
in 2011 I went out once and I got my
first 13a which was snicker and it was
really exciting for me
this year it was the first year I got to
go outside more than once a year I've
done for 40 days and 14 B and a 14 C
[Music]
the main differences is a completely
different terrain rather than just
climbing you have to deal with the
atmosphere the weather the bugs and the
terrain and what you're climbing in so
actually pay attention to your
surroundings more and make sure the
conditions are right whereas the indoors
you can go any day and it doesn't matter
everything's going to be the same so
that's the kind of a different thing to
get used to it didn't take long because
things to meet climbing is climbing no
matter where it is whether it's outside
or inside
[Music]
my mom's awesome I mean the fact that
she could support me during my rock
climbing even when she doesn't like the
outdoors or bugs or trees or effect is
like any of those things and she decides
to climb and Blamey outside just shows
that she had the dedication she's just
very motivating and she helps push me to
be the best that I could be no matter
what you choose to do in life there
going to be obstacles with climbing if
you set your goals high enough there is
no way you're gonna walk through the
door and just immediately just reach
those goals so it's almost like just
through the nature of the sport itself
like you have to be disciplined and so I
think that that definitely makes
climbing an essential pieces life that's
so much bigger than the competition or a
podium or a medal there's always been
two very prominent figures and those
figures are my coaches and my tailor and
Shea Messer
they are the reason here today being
served in the spotlight I would say has
really helped him to grow up as an adult
and helped him to be a young
professional but I mean when he gets
away from cameras
he's a kid like he's a goofball I get an
amazing feeling from tell me that I
don't give in to really support I get
kind of that feeling of euphoria when I
complete a goal that I will work on
whether it's an outside route or it's a
competition inside that I really want to
win that's what I really like about
climbing
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh